ça peut donner quelque chose de très
embarrassant pour notre société et sort
de problème on est en train de se
préparer le shisha continue comme ça
pendant encore dix ans vingt ans et
c'est que des catégories sociales soient
systématiquement mises de côté
[Musique]
m
si des citoyens sont systématiquement
privés de l'accès à l'emploi
elle est là la discrimination et c'est
contre ça qu'il faut goûter
[Musique]
il ya des problèmes d'application qu'ils
sont sérieux
si elle dépasse 10 après porté là dessus
[Musique]
il faut attirer l'attention il faut
sensibiliser le public sans faille et
personnes d'étendre la portée de la loi
par exemple aux ministères du
gouvernement
et puis éventuellement agressive
attaquer le privé on est rendu là
écoutez on s'est jamais prononcé sur le
fait qu'ils aient des cocktails qui en
est pas à la ftq mais en même temps on
constate on constate des problèmes on
constate des problèmes de discrimination
systémique à l' embauche
écoutez ce n'est pas une solution et
qu'on a une mauvaise adéquation que les
personnes qu'on accueille les
qualifications qu'elle possède et les
postes sont à pourvoir sur le marché du
travail
[Musique]